beaucoup
[Musique]
je suis actuellement voit la galerie du
trianon palace situé à versailles en
présence du chef pâtissier eddie
benghanem bonjour bonjour à tous
bienvenue au waldorf astoria merci à
écrire le palace merci beaucoup alors
tout d'abord est ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter nous expliquer ce que ce
qu'est le métier de chef pâtissier je
suis chef pâtissier dans ce bel hôtel
depuis quelques années des herbes dans
lequel je fis ci est en fait mon rôle
est de travailler avec toutes les
équipes de faire plaisir aux clients et
de proposer des gourmandises et des
douceurs tout au long de l'année alors
en face de nous on a ce tea time est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer comment
est ce que vous l'avez penser comment
est ce que vous avez sélectionné
le titane week-end donc un parfait glacé
exotiques donc on va commencer par des
notes acidulées fruité légèrement épicé
donc ananas frais exotiques et ensuite
on va poursuivre avec un cac qui est
assez moderne donc un cake au citron
avec une chantilly au citron on retrouve
le liant qui est un peu sur le kumquat
confier les agrumes et on va finir avec
une tarte au chocolat et vanille on
dénote extrêmement simple très visible
et le but le plus important pour nous
est vraiment de faire plaisir à nos
clients donc les pâtissiers montrent le
samedi et le dimanche pour présenter le
titane à nos clients et on voit ce qui
se passe donc le cierge et j'ai aimé ça
j'ai pas aimé ça pour réajuster
l'expérience on parle vraiment
d'expérience et faire plaisir et donc
vous avez aussi imaginer la bûche de
noël pour les fêtes de fin d'année de
choses elle est assez atypique cette
bûche de noël est ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer comment vous l'avez
penser comment je les pense et c'est
depuis j'avais en tête je me dis j'en
rigolais donc les années précédentes
nous travaillons sur des bûches assez
onirique assez assez élégante sur des
notes de végétal et là je me suis dit
j'ai envie de rigoler le coc vis de nous
a tous marqués donc je voulais rigoler
et je me suis dit comment prendre la
bûche à contre-pied et je me suis dit
mais qu'est ce qu'on mange à noël qu'est
ce qu'est le plat principal à noël la
dinde de noël et je me suis baladée
laden ne va pas passer à la casserole
donc vous avez le chef qui n'est pas
passée à la casserole c'est écrit sur
son tablier chef donc la casserole et en
chocolat une jolie casseront avec
limitation de fond tout est quoi mais
c'est vous c'est que du chocolat voilà
donc à soual et en chocolat le gâteau
est ici donc voilà la gazinière aller à
pas et ça c'est le gâteau les notes du
gâteau son vanille chocolat caramel
pourquoi ces parfums là ce sont des
parfums les préférés des français donc
en fait nous on va mettre la cloche la
part dont la cocotte sous une cloche et
le client n'aura que ça a conservé au
frigo est en fait la cloche vient se
poser
directement sur le gâteau donc c'est un
centre de table les gens sont un petit
peu interloqué pendant pendant repas
musique au scrutin et en faites vous des
clochers voilà et vous découvrez le
gâteau un gâteau pour 6 8 personnes et
pour avoir faire le test en dégustation
six personnes c'est super place à la
dégustation maintenant alors eddie
benghanem comment ça se passe je prends
la première est la première assiette
donc il ya un parfum de glace et donc on
va commencer par le froid est assez
assez douces acidulées mais douce et
puis je vous en prie et l'asie
donc en fait vous avez vous avez parfait
glacé sur des exotiques des notes très
crémeuse très doux sa cellule et gour
monde
et à l'ananas qui au fond bien sûr
mais à l'intérieur du coup à l'orage sur
l'exotisme sar mais vous savez le côté
un peu fruité acidulées un peu bonbon
d'accord n'est peut-être pas tout manger
peut prendre une autre assiette
on a c'est juste un cake ou cake au
citron le même principe que le cake donc
un biscuit riche en amande et la
gentille qui au citron dessus assez
c'est assez c'est beaucoup plus incisive
des biens c'est beaucoup plus puissant
mais c'est le sait le principe d'un
cargo oui on semble beaucoup plus
les saveurs de l' orange citron et bien
sûr complètement
les vraiment principe du cake parce que
le tea time c'est c'est aussi le cake le
fameux cake
c'est très bon
moi c'est mon préféré est celui d'un et
le dernier le dernier démoniaque inégaux
et
là vous prenez le couteau à vous couper
en deux la tard vous allez voir un se
passe à l'intérieur en fait à ganascia
les cuit tout doucement au four il ya
une crème brûlée à la vanille et dessus
il ya une crème au chocolat est bon pour
moi ils l'entendent et le bruit que ça
fait quand même ça croustille à fond
alors dit maya bien ghana pour gâcher
les cuites au four d'accord une commune
crème au lait il ya aussi une crème
brûlée à la vanille d'accord et il ya
une crème légère à la fève de cacao
ça c'est ça c'est super et loisirs ça
croustille
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de bien et
c'est très léger oui mais derrière peu
de sucre dont peu de sucre des cuissons
justes
et en même temps lisible pour qu'on
comprend qu'on mange au goût vanille
chocolat
d'autres activités sont également
proposés trianon palace de versailles
notamment le chalet de noël qui a
installé dans le parc du château est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un petit
peu plus de sûr c'est une petite bosse
bourbon avant d'aller se promener au
château de versailles vous que vous
pouvez acheter une vignette in un cake
ou une boisson chaude ou ses rangs un
petit clin d'oeil à l'automne
merci beaucoup chef pour ce moment
partagé
vous avez bien attiser nos papilles en
tout cas la somme est il